new research warrants depression could
be the side effect of more than 200
commonly prescribed medications they
include beta blockers for blood pressure
birth control pills and acids and
painkillers the new study in the Journal
of the American Medical Association says
more than one-third of Americans are
taking these drugs depression rates more
than tripled when people used at least
three drugs with a possible side effect
compared to people who take none of
these medications or dr. taryn andrew is
a cardiologist at northwell health she
joins us at the table to discuss because
I can hear a lot of people listening to
that feeling a little unsettling when
they hear that news how was the link
discovered between those medications
that a lot of people take and depression
so researchers looked at data from a
survey of about 26,000 Americans over a
nine-year period they asked to look in
their medicine cabinet at their
prescription bottles that they had used
in the last month they also screened
them for depression and they found that
about 37% of those were taking at least
one medication that had a side effect
listed of depression they also found
that the numbers of Americans taking
meds that have side effects listed as
depression increased over the nine-year
period if you were not taking a
medication that had that listed as a
side effect in that survey you had a 5%
chance of depression that's compared to
about a 15 percent risk of depression if
you were taking 3 or more drugs that had
depression listed as a side effect and
as you mentioned all types of drugs oral
contraceptives blood pressure medicines
some stomach antacids pain meds a lot of
numbers there Tara so I'm curious how
worried should people be well I think
it's important to kind of open the
dialogue about polypharmacy and about
side effects and so you know it's hard
to prove this link with this type of
research so it could in fact be that the
drugs are leading to depression however
it could be that people had pre-existing
depression okay it could be that the
chronic conditions they're taking the
medicines for heart conditions cancer
other conditions is what's really
causing the depression they're not the
drugs explaining people at polypharmacy
is meaning that you're taking more than
yet multiple medications well in fact
the number of Americans taking at least
five prescription drugs at the same time
rose sharply in the last decade
yes it's alarming it is and so I think
that people patients pharmacists and
doctors all need to be part of this
discussion so patients need to bring up
their
stree when they go to the doctor and say
I have a history of depression tell me
if that's going to impact the meds I'm
taking do we need to be on these meds
how long do I need to be on them also
doctors need to screen for depression
it's recommended by the US Preventive
task services force that every American
adult be screened for depression and a
lot of times when you go to a doctor you
go to a specialist right a cardiologist
or an orthopedic and they may not be
looking at the whole picture of
everything you're taking so the primary
care doctors really need to be in some
form the quarterbacks analyzing
everything you're taking or a
psychiatrist or psychologist and and
seeing is there something that could be
interacting here and the pharmacists
play a role as well and isn't this a
part of a larger problem which is people
don't look at the side effects so what
should people do who are now listened
who are now paying attention what's the
next thing they should so you can read
the package insert of your prescription
meds but the other issue is some of the
over counter the medicines like proton
pump inhibitors they don't have all
these things listen so talk to your
pharmacist talk to your doctor ask
questions it's a good we're just having
the conversation period because so many
people don't want to say it out loud no
and I think if anything this is peeling
back the curtain on mental health issues
and how important looking for the cause
is whether your meds are causing
depression yes right all right dr.
Turner ulla thanks so much